The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so we
started talking about
transition metals, and at the
end of last time we'd given an
introduction to all the sort of
nomenclature and things you
need to know, and we had just
gotten up to d orbitals, and
when you're talking about
transition metals you're
talking about d orbitals.
So, we're going to start with a
little review of d orbitals,
some of you have seen
this before, maybe
some of you have not.
But here is what you're
going to need to
know about the d orbitals.
You need to know the names of
all the d orbitals, you should
be able to draw the shapes of
the d orbitals, and so the bar
is not too high for this.
You see the drawings that are
in your handouts, you should
be able to do about that
well, it doesn't
have to be super fancy.
But you should be able to draw
their shapes, and you should
also be able to recognize which
d orbital it is -- if
you have a picture of different
d orbitals, you
should be able to name
that d orbital.
So let's just review what the
d orbitals look like.
And in this class, we're always
going to have the same
reference frame, so we're
always going to have the
z-axis up and down, the y-axis
is horizontal, and the x-axis
is coming out of the board
and going into the board.
So, we'll always use that
same description.
It'll often be given, but if
it's not, you can assume
that's what we're
talking about.
So, the first d orbital we'll
consider is d z squared.
It has its maximum amplitude
along the z-axis, and it also
has a little donut
in the x y plane.
So, d x squared minus y squared
has its maximum
amplitude along the x and the
y axis, so directly on-axis
for this particular d orbital.
The next sets of d orbitals have
their maximum amplitudes
off-axis, so they don't
correspond directly to the
axes that I just mentioned,
they're, in
fact, 45 degrees off-axis.
So we have the d y z shown here,
d x z shown here, so
maximum amplitude 45 degrees off
z and x axes, and then z
-- these pictures are a little
bit complicated to see -- d x
y, so it's 45 degrees off
of the x and the y.
And so, here I tried to draw
them all in the same
orientation of axes, which is
a little bit difficult.
So now let's look at them in
terms of where they're drawn
so you can kind of see them a
little bit better, and so why
don't you try to learn to
recognize all of these.
So, what is this one called?
d z squared.
What is this one, so its maximum
amplitude is along x
and y? d x squared
minus y squared.
I think this picture might be
a little -- you might have
somewhat aversion later on, but
this is just good practice
for you in recognizing them.
So here we have one 45 degrees
off-axis, which one is this?
Yup.
And this one over here?
So, y z.
And this last one here?
Yup, we have the x z,
so it's going up and
down for the for z-axis.
So, a little more
practice now.
To show what these look like
again, you want to think in
three dimensions, and on paper
and in most the time in
Powerpoint you're not in three
dimension, so here's a little
movie in three dimensions.
Here you can really see that
donut, so this is d x squared
-- see the maximum amplitude
along z-axis here, and down
here, and the little donut
in the x y plane.
So this one is d x squared
minus y squared.
The maximum amplitudes are right
directly along axis, so
that allows you to distinguish
it from d x y.
So when it's on-axis
here, it's the x
squared minus y squared.
So moving along here, so this is
d x y, so you see that it's
in that axis but it's not
directly on-axis -- the
maximum amplitude is 45 degrees
off, so the orbitals
are in between the axes there.
Now we're looking at one that
has a z in it, and it looks
like it's x z, so that's where
our maximum amplitude is
between the x and the z-axes,
45 degrees off.
And our last one, we
have y and z here.
Again, 45 degrees off-axis
between the y-axis and z-axis.
So, hopefully these little
movies will help cement in
your brain, what the shapes
of these d orbitals are.
All right, so that's d orbitals,
and we're going to
be mentioning d orbitals in
every lecture in this, and you
have to be thinking about what
the shapes of the d orbitals
are to talk about today's
topic, which is
crystal field theory.
So, there are two types of
theories that you may hear of
and that your book mentions --
crystal field theory, and
ligand field theory, and like
most things that you learn
about in freshman chemistry, the
theories were developed to
explain experimental
information.
So there are special properties
of coordination
complexes, so that's where you
have a transition metal in the
middle and you have ligands
all around it, so you have
these coordination complexes
and they have special
properties.
And so people wanted to try to
rationalize these special
properties and they came up
with these two theories.
So, the basic idea behind these
theories is that when
you place a metal ion with the
particular oxidation number in
the center of a coordination
sphere, and you have all these
ligands, these donor ligands,
all surrounding them, that the
energy of the d orbitals is
going to be altered by the
position of those ligands.
So it's all about the d
orbitals, and the d orbitals
are going to experience some
influence from these ligands,
these donor ligands that are
surrounding the metal.
So then, between these two
theories that are used to
explain how these d orbitals
are being affected.
The crystal field theory is
based on an ionic description,
so it considers the ligands
as negative point charges.
It's a very simplified model,
whereas as the ligand field
theory considers covalent, as
well as ionic aspects of
coordination.
It's more powerful it's more
useful, but it's also a bit
more complex, and so we don't
cover it in this of course,
and if you go on and take the
first level of inorganic
chemistry, which is 503, then
you'll hear about this.
But for this course, we're
just going to talk about
crystal field theory.
Even though it's very much
of a simplified model, it
actually works very well.
You can explain quite a few
properties of coordination
complexes just using this
simplified method.
So, crystal field theory,
again, very simple.
It's just considering the
ionic interactions, it
considers the ligands as
negative point charges.
And so, the basic idea is that
ligands, as negative point
charges, are going to have
repulsive effects if they get
close to the d orbitals.
So here is a drawing of a metal,
and so this is metal
abbreviated m, its oxidation
number is m plus here, and it
has ligands all around it.
What is the geometry here?
It's octahedral geometry.
And so we have ligands up and
down along z, ligands along y,
and a ligand going back
along x, and a ligand
coming out along x.
And so here's another picture
of the same thing, the metal
is in the middle, and the
ligands -- in this case, you
have these ammonia ligands or
these little negative point
charges, which are all
along the axes.
You have four along the
equatorial, and one up and one
down, so this is the octahedral
geometry.
And so you can just think about
each of these ligands as
negative point charges.
And so, if the negative point
charge is pointing right
toward a d orbital, that'll
be very repulsive.
If it's not it's
less repulsive.
That's the whole idea behind
this crystal field theory.
So, here again, is just another
little picture, so you
can kind of get the idea that
we're going to be thinking
about the all the shapes of
the d orbitals, and we're
going to think about where
the ligands are.
Today we're going to talk about
octahedral geometry, but
we're also going to go on and
talk about tetrahedral
geometry later.
So here in octahedral geometry,
you can think about
the positions of all of these
negative point charges
surrounding your d orbitals.
And when the d orbitals are
on axis, like the ligands,
there's going to be more
repulsion, so you can see here
that would be quite repulsive
-- you have a negative point
charge by that d orbital.
When the d orbitals are off-axis
and the ligands are
on-axis, that's less
repulsive.
And that's the basic idea.
So, let's look at each one of
these orbitals now in detail
and think about how a ligands
that's pointing directly
toward it is going
to be affected.
So we have the ligands, l, as
these point charges directed
toward the d z squared, and
the d x squared minus y
squared orbitals, and these
would result in
quite a bit of repulsion.
So if you had a ligand right up
here along z, and so that
would be a very close
interaction.
In this case, you're going to
have ligands along x and y,
again pointing directly toward
the orbitals, that would be
quite repulsive.
And I'll just mention, we'll
come back to this later, that
one can think about the case
where you have the octahedral
geometry where the ligands are
in a definite position, and
you can also think about this
sort of hypothetical case
where you have a metal in the
middle and you have the
ligands, here are the little
ligands, and they're
everywhere, there's ligands
everywhere all around.
And so, in this case where you
have ligands everywhere all
around your metal, then all your
d orbitals would have the
same energy, but if you take
the ligands and you isolate
them in particular positions,
then you can consider how the
different shapes of the d
orbitals will be affected.
We'll come back to
that in a minute.
All right, so here we have a
case where our ligands are
on-axis, our orbitals on-axis,
this is a large repulsion.
So, I will tell you that d x
squared and d z squared and d
x squared minus y squared
orbitals are destabilized, and
they are destabilized
by the same amount.
So there's repulsion now, and
so they're destabilized, and
they're destabilized by the
same amount of energy.
So what's it called
when orbitals
are of the same energy?
Yup.
So, d z squared and d x squared
minus y squared are
degenerate.
So, d z squared and d x squared
minus y squared
orbitals are destabilized more
than the other three orbitals,
and let's consider now
why that is true.
So here are our other sets of
orbitals, and remember, here
the maximum amplitude of these
orbitals are 45 degrees
off-axis, whereas our ligands
are all on-axis.
So, the ligand negative charges
are directed in
between these orbitals, not
directly toward them.
So that is stabilized compared
to this hypothetical case
where the ligands are
everywhere, so some of them
will be pointing toward them,
and also stabilized compared
to the other sets of orbitals
where the ligands are now
pointing directly at them.
So these three sets of orbitals
are stabilized
relative to the d z squared and
the d x squared minus y
squared orbitals, and they're
stabilized by the same amount.
So these three orbitals are also
degenerate with respect
to each other.
So then to sort of summarize
this set of orbitals, we have
for d z squared and d x squared
minus y squared, we
have large repulsions by those
negative point charges,
they're pointing directly at the
orbitals, and so they're
destabilized, higher in energy
than the other -- the d x y, d
y z and d x z.
For the d y z, d x z and d x y,
they're smaller repulsion,
because these orbitals are
off-axis, and so the negative
point charges aren't pointing
directly at them.
So they're stabilized relative
to these guys up here.
So that's the whole idea behind
an octahedral case of
crystal field theory.
And we can look at this
just one other way, if
pictures help you.
Here it's a little clearer
that those negative point
charges are pointing directly
toward the orbitals, here I
think you can see that the
negative point charges are not
directly pointing toward
any of the orbitals.
So I'll show you a bunch of
different figures, this all
shows you the same thing, but
some might help you see this
relationship better.
OK, so now we're going to draw
some diagrams. I'm going to
start over here.
So we're going to draw what's
called a crystal field
splitting diagram, and this
is for an octahedral case.
And the diagrams are going to
look different depending on
what the geometry is.
So when we draw this diagram,
energy is going up, and we're
going to start with our 5 d
orbitals, and so this is going
to be the average energy,
the average
energy of our d orbitals.
And so, this is then with a
spherical crystal field.
So that's where the ligands are
distributed around uniformly.
So it's all spherical, they
aren't set up in the
octahedral case yet, our
octahedral diagram's going to
be over here, but this is the
case that this represents.
If you have all your ligands
spherically distributed around
your metal, then the energy
of all the d orbitals are
identical, because every d
orbital has the same amount of
ligands, it's uniform,
it's symmetrical
all around the metal.
And I just want to tell you that
this is was very exciting
to me when I saw this.
I've been teaching this class
for a while, and I never had a
real spherical crystal field
around my metal before.
And then I walked into Walgreens
one day, and I was
very excited to see that
Walgreens sold spherical
crystal fields.
I mean you never know what
you're going to get.
I'm a big fan of Walgreens,
I've found a lot of good
stuff, toys for my dog,
etcetera, but
this was really amazing.
So I asked the cashier on the
way out whether they knew they
were selling spherical
crystal fields, and
they did not actually.
So, you just never know what
you're going to get.
OK, so in that case, where the
ligands are uniform all
around, the energy
is the same.
But now, if we have an
octahedral crystal field over
here, so we have our octahedral
crystal field, then
we get some splitting.
So some of our orbitals are
going to be destabilized, and
they'll be higher
in energy here.
So we have the d x squared
minus y squared, and d z
squared over here are going
to be higher in energy.
And we're going to have three
that lower in energy, so we'll
have our d x y, our d y z, and
our d x z over here, will be
lower in energy.
This difference is called the
octahedral field splitting
energy, because it's the amount
of energy that the
octahedral field is split.
So over here, we can put this
is for the octahedral case,
crystal field splitting
energy.
And again, some of the orbitals
go up in energy, some
of the orbitals go down in
energy, and the overall energy
needs to be conserved.
So, if two orbitals go up in
energy, and three go down in
energy, then to have everything
add up, you can say
that three go up in energy by
3/5, and two, these three
orbitals are going to
go down by 2/5.
So overall, the energy of the
system is maintained.
OK, so that's a crystal field
splitting diagram for an
octahedral case, and now let's
look at some examples of this.
So let's look at an example,
and we're going to have a
chromium system that has
three n h 3 ligands
and three b r ligands.
Now, you tell me what the
d count of that is.
Let's just take 10
more seconds.
They're not as high overall, but
still more people got the
right answer.
So, let's take a look at this.
What's the oxidation
number of bromium?
What is it?
Bromium?
What's 1 b r minus?
What's its oxidation number.
Minus 1.
There are three of them.
What about ammonia?
0.
So, 3 times 0.
And the overall charge
of this is 0, so
there's nothing up there.
So what does that mean
about chromium?
Plus 3.
All right, so now we have to
figure out the d count.
So the d count is going to equal
the -- and the periodic
table, the group number, so if
you switch to my slides, we
can see what that is.
So what is that for chromium?
6.
And then we have 6 minus 3,
because our oxidation number
is 3, and so we have
a d 3 system.
So, did some of you get
this wrong because
you stopped too early?
Here, the answer, if you had 3,
you could have stopped with
oxidation number and still
gotten it correct.
So that's a d 3 system.
So, we're going to worry about
three d electrons, and we're
going to put three d electrons
into our splitting diagram.
OK, so if you had a hypothetical
spherical crystal
field, you would have your one's
in here, but now let's
consider what happens in
the octahedral case.
So we can come down here.
Am I going to put my first
electron down here or up here?
Down.
Oh, I just realized that I
didn't put two things on this
diagram, so these are in your
notes, but these diagrams have
little abbreviations in them
for the orbital levels.
So we have an e g and t 2 g, and
that's an abbreviation for
the names of the ts of orbitals,
which you'll see
later is very convenient in
terms of writing things out.
All right, so we're going
to put them down here.
Am I going to put two of them
together with the spins up in
the first orbital?
No.
So you know that that is not
good, give you the same four
quantum numbers, you don't
want to do that.
So, we can put them in.
What about just putting in a
paired set over here yet?
No.
They have the same energies
here, so we're going to put
them in all singly, and
then we're done.
So we put three electrons
in these three orbitals.
Now we can introduce a couple
other terms, which is where I
realized I forgot to
put the labels on.
So, you'll often
be asked for --
OK, you'll often be asked for
something called the d n
electron configuration.
And so here you can use the
abbreviations for the
orbitals, so we point three
electrons in to the t 2 g
orbitals, so we can just
say that's t 2 g
raised to the three.
So that let's someone know that
you have three electron
in the set of orbitals that
are stabilized in an
octahedral crystal field.
Then we can consider something
else that's called c f s e,
and I think I should have --
OK, so I'll write that out.
So, this is the crystal field
stabilization energy.
So it's not the crystal field
splitting energy, it's the
stabilization energy, which
indicates how much those
electrons are stabilized by
being in an octahedral field,
rather than this hypothetical
spherical crystal field.
And so what we can do there is
you see that you have three
electrons in those lower sets
of orbitals, and those
orbitals are stabilized by 2/5
times the octahedral crystal
field splitting energy.
And so that gives an answer of
minus 6/5 times the octahedral
crystal field splitting
energy.
So that's how much those
electrons are stabilized.
So they are lower in energy --
see, the average energy is
much, much higher in this
hypothetical case, but because
of having this octahedral
geometry, and there are only
three electrons to consider,
they all go into the
stabilized energy, and so
they're stabilized by minus
6/5 times whatever the
octahedral crystal field
splitting energy is for
this particular case.
So, now let's look at
another example.
So let's look at an example of
a coordination complex -- you
have manganese and you have
six water ligands and some
chlorides hanging around.
So why don't you tell me what
the oxidation number is for
this now -- not the d count,
but the oxidation number?
OK, so let's just take
10 more seconds.
OK, so let's just look at that
one for a minute, people did
very well on that.
So, what's the overall charge in
this coordination complex?
So we can write this out here.
Our six ligands and we say that
here it's plus 3 overall,
because we have three chloride
ions hanging around with a
negative charge.
So this tells us that the
overall charge on the
coordination complex
had to be plus 3.
And this again is 0, so that
means that is plus 3.
So, people did very
well on that.
All right, so then what
is the d count?
What is it?
4, right.
So we have 7 minus 3 is 4,
so we have a d 4 system.
All right, so now, if you look
up there, we have to make a
decision about that fourth
electron. three electrons were
easy, four makes
it complicated.
Do we put the fourth one
down in the lower
set or do we go up?
So there are two possibilities
here.
So I have two diagrams
drawn over here.
And you might be in a case where
you have a small crystal
field splitting energy, or you
might be in a case where you
have a large crystal field
splitting energy.
And so, there are two
different ways the
electrons can go.
So over here where you have a
small crystal field splitting
energy, that's called
a weak field.
And when you have a big
splitting energy, that's a
strong field.
So, with the weak field there's
not that much of an
energy difference
between them.
And so, when you're putting in,
you do your first three
electrons, that's always
going to be the same.
But then the fourth electron, in
this case, if there's not a
big difference in the energy, if
it's pretty small, if it's
a weak field, you can put that
fourth one up there.
Because it takes energy to pair
the electrons up, and so
you're asking the question, does
it take more energy to
pair them, or does it take
more energy to put one
in the upper set?
And for a weak field you say
that the crystal field
splitting energy is smaller than
the pairing energy or p
e, so p e is the
pairing energy.
And so it takes more energy to
pair than it does to bump one
electron up to the
higher level.
So that's what a weak field
situation would look like.
Now in a strong field situation,
boy, there's a big
splitting difference, a big
energy difference here.
So in this case, the crystal
field splitting is much larger
than p e, that pairing energy
for the electron.
So it's better to pair,
then to put one up.
I can't even reach those,
that's really far up.
So I'm not going to do
that, I'm just going
to put them in here.
I'll put the first three in,
and then the fourth one is
going to go down where
I can reach it.
I don't have the energy
to put it up there.
So that's a strong field.
Weak field I can handle, strong
field I'm going to try
pair them all up.
So, now we can write the
different d n electron
configurations for these two.
So, in this case, if we
have our d n electron
configuration, so we
have three in the t
2 g, we have three.
And in the e g set we have one,
so that is our electron
configuration for this
weak field case.
And for the strong field case,
we didn't put any up in the e
g, so we just have t
2 g, four electrons
in that set of orbitals.
OK, so let's just put up what
we've done here, and introduce
another term, which are high
spin and low spin.
So we have these two cases
here, and again, we're
considering how big is this
octahedral crystal field
splitting energy compared
to a pairing energy.
The energy involved in pairing
electrons together.
In a weak field, the splitting
energy is small, so electrons
are placed singly with spins
parallel to the fullest extent
in all the sets of orbitals.
In this other case with the
strong field, the pairing
energy is smaller than the
splitting energy -- strong
field you have a big
splitting energy.
And so, in that case, with the
splitting energy is large,
you're going to put all your
electrons in and pair them up
in t 2 g and don't put any
electrons in the e g sets of
orbitals until you completely
filled your t 2 g set.
So, the net result of this is
for a weak field, you have the
maximum number of unpaired
electrons, so see, you have a
maximum number, you have
four electrons,
all four are unpaired.
So that's the maximum number
of unpaired electrons, and
this is referred to
as high spin.
And in the other case, you have
the minimum number of
unpaired electrons that you can
have, and so you have this
one set that's paired here,
so that would be
considered a low spin case.
We can also talk about the
stabilization energy of these
two cases, and so we have
the crystal field
stabilization energy.
So why don't you go ahead and
tell me for a weak field case,
what is our stabilization
energy?
Let's just take 10
more seconds.
OK, pretty good.
So let's work this out.
So, first we consider how many
electrons we have in the lower
set of orbitals, so
we have three.
Those three are stabilized
by 2/5.
And then we have one in the
upper set, so we have one at
3/5 times the octahedral
crystal
field splitting energy.
So this ends up with minus 3/5
times the octahedral crystal
field splitting energy.
And notice why a is not correct
-- you don't have the
symbol for the octahedral
crystal
field splitting energy.
On a test, you need to make
sure that you remember to
write this term, so this was
a little test so that you
hopefully emphasize that you
want to have that there.
All right, so that's
for this one.
Let's look at the low spin case,
the strong field case,
and do our crystal field
splitting energy for that.
So in this case we're going to
have four electrons times
minus 2/5 times the octahedral
crystal field splitting
energy, so that's equal to minus
8/5 times the octahedral
crystal field splitting energy,
and some books will
also indicate, and they'll say
plus p e to indicate that
there's pairing energy that's
associated there.
So it's not quite as beneficial
as one might think.
You do have a lot of electrons
in these in lower energy
orbitals, but you did have to
pair some of them, so you had
one, and if two of them are
paired, you can see
sometimes 2 p e.
So, some books will do that,
some books will not.
So I just wanted to mention
that both are OK.
And whether you're asked to
write that or not, and the
question will say include the
pairing energy, so you know
whether you're supposed to do
that or not, that there is
that energy associated
with pairing in this
strong field case.
OK, so let's look at another
example, and then you should
be all set to do these
problems for
an octahedral field.
So we'll take our
electrons down.
All right, so let's at a
case of cobalt plus 2.
So let's consider how many we're
going to put in, the
oxidation number is?
Plus 2.
And what is the d count then?
What group number?
9 minus 2 is 7, so we're
doing a d 7 system.
All right, so now for the weak
field case here, why don't you
tell me what is the correct
electron distribution.
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
OK, very good.
This is the weak field case, so
in this case, we are going
to fill up singly all of the
orbitals, because the
splitting energy is less than
the pairing energy, so we're
going to put them to the fullest
extent possible before
we have to pair.
So we have 7, so we're going to
do 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, and now
we have to pair.
We have no -- we've used up
all our orbitals, so we're
going to start pairing down here
in the lower energy, so
that would be 6, 7.
So we had no choice, we had to
pair them, but because it was
a weak field, we filled
them all up singly
first before we paired.
So now let's consider what we're
going to do down here.
Now remember, this is a strong
field, so there's a big
splitting energy, so it takes
less energy to pair them than
to reach this higher level.
So first we put them
in the same way --
1, 2, 3, but now that we have
the 3 in, it's better to pair
than to bring them up here.
So we'll do 1, 2, 3, we'll
pair them all up.
Now it's all filled, we
have no other choice
but to go up here.
So, we have these very different
cases depending on
the splitting energy.
So what controls the
splitting energy?
Well, what controls the
splitting energy is nature of
the ligands, so we're going to
be talking about that next
time, and you'll recognize for
certain kinds of ligands
you're going to have a strong
field, and other kinds you'll
have a weak field.
But right now we're not talking
about that, we're just
showing those two
possibilities.
So, for this system, is this
going to be a high spin or a
low spin system?
So, this will be high spin,
because we have the maximum
amount of unpaired electrons.
And over here we're going to
have a low spin system.
We have the minimum
number possible of
the unpaired electrons.
All right, so let's finish this
up now, and do our d n
electron configurations
and our crystal
field splitting energies.
So, for this case, we're going
to have in our t 2
g system, how many?
5.
And in e g?
2.
And for our splitting energy,
we have 5 times minus 2/5
times the octahedral crystal
field splitting energy plus 2
times plus 3/5, and what does
that end up equaling?
Minus 4/5 times the
octahedral crystal
field splitting energy.
And we could also optionally put
2 p e because we have two
sets paired.
All right, so let's look at
our strong field system.
How many do we have
in our e 2 g set?
6.
What about e g?
1.
And for our splitting energy
then, we have 6 times minus
2/5 times the octahedral crystal
field splitting energy
plus 1 times 3/5, and what
is that going to equal?
Minus what?
9/5.
And how many pairing energies?
three pairing energies, great.
I think you have
that part down.
Next time we get more
complicated, we're going to
talk about types of ligands,
we're going to talk about
tetrahedral, we're going to talk
about square planar, and
that's, of course, after
the exam on Wednesday.
So, good luck, everyone, with